folks Joe and Sal here from the taste
buds podcast we are doing our very first
live live stream episode live stream
episode when May 10th May 10th mark your
calendars tickets are going to be
available soon for pre-sale there's
going to be a ton of surprises there's
gonna be guests there's gonna be a
Premiere that night of should we tease
it not yet okay not yet but it's a big
one it's a big something yeah something
very big we've been teasing it for a
while it's coming finally the live
stream May 10th also merch is still
available for the taste buds podcast go
and get you some uh it's available at my
website jodarosainfo.com or
salvocanocomedy.com and also we are both
on the road doing live dates we've got
tons we've only got time to name a few I
next coming up will be in Michigan in
several cities uh and then also in
Illinois for several cities and in New
York at the crane theater anyway just
check out my website joeinfo.com for all
the info on that plus Joey roses
Remington Street Manhattan Joey get a
sandwich affordable guy sandwiches and
drinks I'm on the road with the guys uh
this is our first tour since before the
pandemic our fifth International tour
tickets are on sale right now and
impracticaljokerslive.com there's tons
of cities and tons more will be added
next up March 24th in Green Bay the 25th
of Milwaukee the 26th in Rosemont then
we're going to Seattle and Portland in
April as well as Bangor Maine and Boston
again and then later on so forth it's a
lot of Ohio a lot of Texas uh two in St
Louis and practicaljokerslive.com brand
new episodes of Impractical Jokers every
Thursday night at 10 o'clock on TBS and
True TV season 10 out right now
they coming to the mic talking about the
[Music]
Foos you weren't too tired to go to that
party were you
what's your mustard
folks I'm here
on the taste buds pod six minutes away
you want to pick up your mic we're going
yeah we're rolling here when you start
like that huh Wendy's doing something
different oh well then I did that's why
I didn't know okay uh
uh I'm just giving Sal [__]
it happened yeah yeah today you've been
a lot on the t a s t e b
I ever give you [__] we have Chrissy D's
Premiere party last night yeah and you
weren't out there now I wanted to go but
I didn't know I couldn't to the last
minute and then bro I'm tired man I know
but I've been just so I've been giving
you [__] about not going to that yeah
but then you start talking about how you
went to the De La Soul Premiere uh the
streaming Premiere which was a week ago
yeah yeah and I was saying well you
found the energy to go to that didn't
you well two things on that I was
already very close by in the city when
it started I wasn't yesterday I was not
even around and the other thing is I had
someone uh that I was meeting up with
from Atlanta that was here so you know I
had I had to kind of do that okay
how was the party thanks for bringing me
by the way no plus one babe no plus one
would not you had to see the scene
outside people they were just being so
strict about it it was weird it had
nothing to do with deal I saw Amazon ran
it all oh and that's always good it was
just like the suits like as far as like
the the party itself like the lists and
stuff and it was this why did Amazon run
it because I think they were perfunctor
I think they were uh they had a uh a
play in like the streaming oh really oh
okay well hey it's great I'll tell you
that
how
it was great so weird that that the
amount of people that was amazing it was
great it's so weird that Dove passed as
the streaming thing was about to happen
uh and it almost seemed like the
streaming thing was it wasn't but it
almost seemed as if like they did it as
a celebration of his life it became a
celebration that night yeah yeah it was
crazy timing but I mean what a treat
having not
Oh I thought it sounded for a second
that I said what a treat in about him
passing continue that's not what I meant
obviously what
can we cut that are you nuts what am I
being crazy yeah really sorry I didn't
know I didn't know just finish your
thoughts my thought was what a treat to
have all those albums now unbelievable I
feel bad saying what a treat
in the light of also having lost
such a pillar but you said what it what
a treat to have access to the albums
Mike vinoya is our guest today
yeah Mike Sears getting to it
wow no this is fantastic I wish you
didn't even bring me up no no it's like
watching an old couple on a bus
I was getting to it hi buddy yeah how
you doing man I'm great did you get that
at the event no oh yeah it was Sales
Plus One
no I got this I watched Maceo say that
they got all their merch money yep so I
hopped it right online and bought merch
is that new brand new they got the store
up now yeah I like that [__] up there
yeah yeah wait so why did you say you
bought because before we started
recording you said you waited till March
3rd well because March 3rd was when
their stuff went live it was just oh wow
okay yeah the stream is a terrific fit
that could blind that fit I like it yeah
it's a large and I'm normally kind of
nervous about that but um I don't know
if I should wash it it's one of those
okay I'll have to wash it and like hang
dry well also too that's a hip hop large
I know which I would think would run a
lot bigger right that's why I got large
that's why I didn't get extra large but
I totally could have got but that's the
opposite of what I'm saying oh I see
what you're saying the large okay yes
yeah we're showing the same I'm a weird
thing where it's like I'm always an
extra large with wise but then I get it
and it's too long yeah and if I get a
largest the right length but it's tight
so I was gonna just get an XL and shrink
it but I thought hip hop like right
exactly right but yeah I have no
consistency in what I order at all it's
always a shot in the dark but anyway
back to the to the show thank you
amazing it was really cool it's cool to
be there
uh but it was cool it was uh
Queen Latifah money love came out and
did some Eclipse yeah uh Mike G of the
Jungle Brothers was there uh common did
anybody buy romance uh all the originals
Did they perform or did they just come
out and like kind of something a lot of
them performed yeah so who performed
what did March do
Simon says yeah did uh Latifa do ladies
first I might have done that but yeah
in the middle yeah
jungle Brothers Straight Out The Jungle
he didn't do anything I don't think that
thing tribe
so Q-tip was there and so was Busta but
they didn't perform
I don't even I didn't even see them but
my friend told me by any chance they
were not they were Native tongues they
did uh we had Red Alert okay and you had
the originals you had with Tony touch
you had a uh uh uh Medina Tony Toka yeah
yeah he had he had all those guys it was
Medina Rich Medina I don't think I Know
Rich Medina the DJs uh they had uh who
were the originals I mean what do you
mean by The Originals oh they go by the
original like it's like four or five DJs
oh they were like a crew yeah they do
like yeah yeah okay do you know the
originals Mike no
New York Guys Hot 97 got like the early
days yeah yeah I'm totally forgetting I
I wrote and Chappelle was Chappelle
jumped up and did like the countdown to
how
yeah like right in the middle like okay
Paz had the mic and was saying thanks to
everybody and then Chappelle came in and
thanked them and then but she were there
I watched it online oh okay yeah black
sheep drays of Black Sheep Black Thought
performers perform he
he did choice is yours I assume he did
yeah did uh
Capri was there Clark can't stretch did
Paws and Maceo do any daylight songs
they must have right didn't they do body
yeah
yeah they didn't do I mean it was it was
it was Mayhem in there but it was they
did they did do something I was up in
the balcony some of it so I couldn't I
wish you said a party that Stretch
Armstrong was DJing and it's
it's so cool that he's still out there
DJing parties yeah in New York uh like
yeah it's nice I love it wasn't Maceo
doing some stuff in the East Village a
lot or Alphabet City like I thought like
Sunday nights Dante's friends yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and I think uh
I think because I think that's how they
maybe met I might be I think so and you
know oh stretching babito were they
there those guys that's Dante and I
would sit in his Jeep outside of like
stand up New York and he would just play
me old like he had like old tapes of
stretch and babito like that show yeah I
don't know if Bobby though I feel like
that show was like and I never got to
hear it because I didn't live in New
York but I feel like that show was kind
of like the one of the original podcasts
because you knew it as the two you know
what I mean yeah it was a big music show
he knew it as these two co-hosts it was
it was you know it wasn't a morning Zoo
kind of thing it wasn't a morning radio
kind of thing yeah like that's kind of
like uh like a prototype for podcasting
you know what I mean yeah yeah
they probably would have went on such a
tour even though Dave didn't like the
tour I bet they would have done one big
tour after all the music went I saw them
live a few times it was fun I can't
believe I didn't mention this last time
I did student affairs uh for my college
I was on the board of the events board
and I was in charge of music and I
produced the De La Soul show they came
to my school
I can't believe I forgot about this
did you meet him yeah they came to my
school or a school like Kutztown
University and I produ but produced the
show meaning like booked them yeah I
booked it and I had to oversee
everything and I was a kid I didn't know
what I was doing and the food like their
Rider requested certain things and I got
the things made by the cafeteria
which was really shitty but I didn't
know any better I thought that's just
what you had to do and their Road
manager
was not happy about it like he was kind
of like what is this man come on and I
went to De La Soul and apologized
profusely and they were so [__] cool
about it that's awesome and especially
how are they gonna treat you honestly
well they could have been dicks really
I'm a kid people came to the school that
were dicks it's their man's job to be
the dick you know they were but but they
were they were I it was genuinely nice
it wasn't that they were just like don't
worry about it they were literally like
like positive was was like laughing he's
like you want me to eat two sandwiches
yeah and he was like he was like Hey man
shoot the guy in the back who [__] it
up man like you know when he was like
laughing like they were really really
nice they put on an amazing show yeah uh
that was the stand-up I had two standout
hip-hop events at my school that and
then ice tea came and lectured when he
was doing his college lectures and I met
lecture about what
he just talked about life like his
experience and his philosophy and his
take on things and whatever and I had
I had the coolest moment it was the
Catalyst for my professional career and
performing
iced tea when I was he was the Catalyst
for you having a career in performance
yeah please continue because I'm being I
don't like the energy coming with how
have I not like well how do I not know
this well it wasn't like he made a phone
call for me
give me the most inspiring thing I've
ever received uh because when I was 10
11 or 10 years old 11 I got iced tea
which one is it I got iced tea power the
cassette iced tea power it was stickered
it was the first stickered album I ever
got my mom made me listen to the entire
cassette with her sticker meaning
explicit yeah
and she approved of it because she said
he taught a lesson
you listen to the Ice-T album
and then she approved it afterwards
because it was a message I don't like
the language but he teaches a lesson I'm
going to let you keep this record
and she did I remember the last thing
two Live Crew in my room and like you
know call it yeah I call it seventh
grade maybe yeah and I just blessed it
my mom would was would freak out she'd
be like dude what are you listening to
you can't be listening to this music
like this is you shouldn't listen to
this this is this is terrible and
everything I was like my it's just a
song oh my that was like I wasn't like
allowed to have that yeah yeah like um
so uh ice tea came to my school and
spoke me and my friend Pat Knowles went
me and Pat had a rap group at the time
uh and we were obsessed with cool Keith
the name of the rap group yeah uh the
one ones was the name of the rap group
The what the one one I know you drew it
on your notebooks what did it look like
oh no I'm sorry I correct I'm sorry
excuse me that was the original name and
then we changed it to Stevie in the
example because he was Stevie and I was
example you were an example yeah yeah
which at the time how many X an example
yeah just one all right but it was ex
Dash because I was like Excalibur like
got it completely and you would come on
a verse and be like yo this is an
example
I would say ex caliber
[Music]
that's so funny yo I go by the example
and he's like and I'm Stevie
the reason Pat was Stevie he would call
himself MC Stevie was because he always
when we started doing it he said he
wanted to sample the deer hunter when
they're playing Russian roulette and the
guy's going do it Stevie do it Steve and
he was like I want to sample that before
my verse comes in we never did anyway
yeah if I listeners probably don't know
what you're talking about yeah oh yeah
right but anyway we went to see Ice-T
speak and I was telling Pat Stevie uh I
go dude this is the guy that made me
want to do music like this is the guy
that made me want to do it like I can't
believe we're going to actually be in
the same room as him right were you like
hello Mr T I'm the example well I'll get
to it
I go by example I didn't want to tee him
off okay
come on
I don't know what you're looking for
that I don't know what you're looking
for looking for folks oh folks I'll give
you a focus on that folks come on babe
uh anyway he uh so we went in and we
were obsessed with cool Keith it was one
cool Keith at the time had put out the
Dr Octagon record and Doctor Doom and
whatever we're obsessed with him real
avant-garde rap we were obsessed
and uh I stated a q a so this is two
parts I see the Q a is the first part I
raised my hand he called on me and I
said ice I just want to know what you
think golden mice yeah you went first
name right away yeah wow
tea before ice no okay I said ice I
don't know I I just called him ice no I
think that's all right I introduced my
buddy to Stone Cold Steve Austin he was
like hi Mr cold Mr cold
it was being funny yeah that's great
that's really if he did was being
financially yeah
um he uh so I said we just want to know
what you think about cool Keith and
these guys in front of us started
laughing at us
and they were like cool Keith who the
[__] are you talking about like and they
were making like yeah and iced tea goes
cool keys to illest [__] alive
we're like and he goes I got an album
coming out with cool Keith and we were
like what you know it was like Wow mind
blown right that was an awesome moment
but then
uh I would have been like right to the
people in front of me like you [__]
[__] yeah well you wouldn't have okay
Excalibur I walked out anyway so then
after the show I was like trying to talk
to him and they kept taking him like his
team was taking him to different doors
because they were trying to avoid
getting like mobbed or whatever yeah
and I I like figured it out where they
went and I I found them outside and um
uh all these guys were around them
giving them demo tapes and stuff for
sure and being like ice put me on put me
on all this stuff
and he like he was like cool man cool he
was being gracious but you could tell it
was a little like uh and then he just
turned and looked at me I was standing
like like this and I turned and looked
at he looked at me
and I would dude I was almost I was so
nervous I was shaking I was [__]
shaking and I go ice I don't have a demo
tape to give you I don't want to ask you
for any favors I just want to tell you
I've been listening to you for half of
my life and you're the person who made
me want to do music
and he grabbed my hand
and he pulled me in and he goes that's
what's up so then do it get out there
and bang some [__] heads no I swear
to God and I go okay okay I will I will
all right all right yeah
then he turned and then and then I heard
him go all right so we're going to strip
club
[Laughter]
away from him and you're like I now go
above the example
yeah I met t on South Beach and New
Year's Eve and I just said Happy New
Year teen he went happy New Year brother
and that was it and I was like yeah that
was my only one tea I said t but I used
to have to play the video game on the
months with tea what yeah where uh micro
uh uh uh Xbox launch party
this is this is I love you I love you
seven degrees of ice like family I love
you like family sure we are family when
we're here we're family yeah it said the
OG's but this is what I hate about you
no matter how good your story is sounds
like well actually
I uh went to his house for Thanksgiving
that guy that's more famous I'm not
saying I'm not that guy who's like I
have a better service he was my
confirmation sponsor I'm not saying you
one up I'm not saying you do it to one
up you just always
you always have a heavier story I didn't
remember that so you I don't remember
that until you brought it up but how is
my name different you you talk to him he
inspired you to perform better than your
name that's pretty incredible man no he
didn't change my name yeah you know he
gave you the power he gave me the power
to change the name the power now Joe do
you have a favorite rhyme you've ever
written and can you do it pimp why are
you starting [__] why do you search it
up he comes in today
Shady Rays folks Jay d Ray
Shady rays are durable
built to tackle all of life's Outdoor
Adventures these are sunglasses that are
just as good or even better uh
potentially in my opinion than the
expensive ones uh and you're getting
them for a fraction of the price that's
where I point out the expensive ones
Rays have polarized lenses for Crystal
Clear Vision and strong sun protection
that's the real test of a good pair of
sunglasses how about this every pair of
shady Rays is backed by the
industry-leading lost and broken
Replacements program break or lose your
pair
the second you take them out of the box
they will send you a replacement pair
free that's just good business right a
shady Rays isn't happy unless what
unless you're happy okay that's why you
there giving you 30 days to try them out
if you don't like them you can exchange
them or return them for free I mean come
on guys the quality is as good as as
expensive sunglasses yes yeah and I like
that uh the Shady race IMPACT program
works with non-profits Worldwide so with
every order you're helping uh have an
impact on the lives of children and
young adults uh like building playsets
for Pediatric cancer patients or
creating Adventures for young adults
with cancer and Ms uh you and Shady
raids are making an impact together
that's even better what's better than
getting one pair of shady rays and not
worrying if you break them or lose them
getting two go to shadyraise.com
tastebuds and news code taste buds for a
limited time when you buy one pair of
shady Rays you'll get a second pair free
that's shady s-h-a-d-y raise r a y s.com
slash taste buds code taste buds to get
a second pair of shady Race Free
shadyraise.com
folks uh I have been using better help
for months and months and months and
months and months uh I can't say enough
good stuff about this program I am
somebody who has needed therapy
throughout my life I have needed help in
tackling life's problems I I've needed
help in reducing the stress uh the the
anxiety that I get from gargan what
feels like gargantuan tasks that life
presents to me and better help has been
instrumental in helping me do just that
in in in and the podcast because this
podcast is sponsored by better yes
absolutely uh it's it's close it out
babe I have benefited from therapy uh
and I want to tell look I can tell you
this I learned recently
I learned recently that I do a
self-judgment thing to myself
uh where no matter what it is I do good
not good
bad not bad whatever whatever it is I
put myself on trial in my head
instantaneously and tell myself that I'm
wrong oh this is not a slide against
better help but I could have told you
that yeah if you're thinking of starting
therapy but no I'm saying like I do this
and bet one thing that's helped me with
Better Health is not just finding a
therapist that can talk to me about this
that can that is helping me learn to not
judge myself in those ways to help me
understand that the entire world isn't
speaking about me Illy at all times okay
uh it has allowed me to do that in an
understanding and accommodating way
where the schedule is flexible I can do
it on my phone at the last minute we can
switch over and do a zoom if we want
entirely online it's it's amazing he
sends me worksheets all these things
it's all in the app it's an incredible
incredible affordable service it's great
therapy why not give better help a try
you just fill out the brief
questionnaire and they match with a
licensed therapist uh and you can switch
their percent anytime for no additional
charge discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com taste
buds today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
help.com taste buds
my favorite rhyme I ever wrote uh was uh
I'm not gonna wrap it but I'll recite it
it was uh it was uh oh then we'll wrap
it in the style that we think it is yeah
yeah yeah yeah everybody will Joey
everybody will it's going around the
table okay we're passing this around the
horn give us the lyrics
give us the bars
what kind of beat yo going through his
wait hold on a second I I gotta remember
this this the second to last line hold
on a second
give us an example I'm [__] um
let's go baby I'm blanking on I can't
remember the the key line in it yeah I
forgot it no sorry to disappoint guys
you're ready to go man I'm sure you were
uh the Beats not helping me remember
[Laughter]
I'm I'm actually kind of embarrassed
that I can't right so many careers ago
though I mean you got to give yourself
like did you have a verse that was about
us a concept one career ago
I remember I had a lot of like like like
movie references and I remember I had a
Star Wars reference
before like everybody on Earth
referenced Star Wars because this was
like 98. I felt like I was kind of still
the full Luke Skywalker before George
Lucas uh uh I said I remember I said I
ripped I ripped spots on I ripped spots
on tattooing with Androids and bounty
hunters I thought that was a cool line
and at the time it was like a cool line
okay what would that rhyme with that's
what I can't I can only remember like
one of the lines I can't remember the
other lines uh who produced this Beats
me and Stevie produced all the bees on
what well no that's not true we had a
guy Tandy
no we had a castle no we had we had
computer programs and [__] that were
yeah that we produce yeah but but
initially we had a guy that we worked
with his name was Brian and he produced
a lot of the beats and then when we got
out of college and started doing stuff
after school again Pat and I bought
equipment and stuff
dude I was gonna do this I maxed out
credit cards to buy production equipment
like I shopped I had a I had a demo CD
at the time of Beats I produced that I
would shop around to local uh music
studios and I loved Philly yeah like
trying to get like a gig as a producer
like trying to get people to bring me in
why don't you do that now you would sell
Beats now at this at the show I don't
really make them I still do music like
that I haven't made beats in a long time
beat by DeRosa would sell
but they're like they're not like that's
the problem is like the beat like the
beats that people like now are shown not
like the Beats we did dead yeah but you
don't know
I guess they're goat cheese and
pistachio old school heads orange and
red I would I want to hear it it's my
least favorite meat on the salad on
planet Earth really I love it
smells like feet I just eats and I
thought I was uh [__] blood I know
yeah that happens
really oh God sorry no I just woke my
wife up in the middle of the night and I
was like I don't mean to wake you up but
I think I'm dying and she's like she
went in the back like I left it in there
like the whole thing and she's like
beats dude they're beats remember we got
a juicer and we've been juicing beets
all day and I'm like yeah Chrysler told
me that he went to stanhope's
and he said they partied all night and
then the next morning they had to fly
together and stand out made them shakes
and he drives the shake and then he went
to the bathroom and he came out and he
was like damn and stand up was like
what's the matter and he goes
there were beets in the shake relax and
uh and I go what happened then he goes
we went to the airport and got [__] up
oh God those these are the asparagus of
[__] like it goes right down into it
it's quick you know it's funny you say
this right I had a little meal just now
right before we started but I just had
it and then I went to the restroom
before we started here so I ate and I
went to the restroom one minute later
and my pee smelled like asparagus
already yeah that's just instantane it's
weird it's like pregnancy it's like how
does it do that I think what is it if
you have the enzyme it doesn't
asparagus yeah but immediately though
I want to hear you sometimes they pee
and I go oh I had asparagus
did you did you ever want to pick
Stevie's cool lines
what I just remember one of Stevie
school life he's sitting here in silence
he goes when it rains you're who i'm
blaming your man had a couple drinks and
thinks he's Matt Damon
[Laughter]
wow I don't get it huh
okay your man's had a couple of drinks
what an [__] it's a college when we
were 18. why am I an [__] I'm
literally trying to understand it I'm
trying to I it just sounds cool but I
didn't catch I didn't catch the Milly
Vanilli reference I'm sure they didn't
either because they don't know it but
I'm I was connected
I'm sorry when it rains that's what I'm
blaming Blame It On The Rain but it's a
little more clear then sorry also I was
connecting Matt Damon to rain and I was
like am I missing was he in The
Rainmaker
right he was in a movie called The Rain
Man yeah he was right yeah
I'm sure I'm being invested and
interested in what you had to say and
and to continue the conversation about
it that's enough
that's right you guys we're on some [__]
today bro I'm not you think everyone's
against you I always do
and they usually are let's be honest
they usually are no but I'm on the other
end of this couch a lot and a lot of
times I'm not and I get pegged to be
that I don't mean to Peg you I mean your
crosshairs a lot just by by inherently
I'm in your crosshairs you're only 50
accurate probably I feel like listen man
when I Peg you yeah really that's
empowering
thank you
uh I'm kind of nervous I'm not nervous
I'm just watching I brought you guys
I'll just listen I brought you guys a
gift oh yeah let's get to the food part
of the show well when I was a kid I used
to have to give my friend his uh my my
hip-hop tapes and CDs and he would have
to make me copies and I'd have to label
them like Rolling Stones Greatest Hits
or the Beatles Because wouldn't let me
happen really yeah totally absolutely
and then I'd listen to him in my
headphones and I would be rapping and my
mother's like what's that and then I'd
get caught and have to listen to the
whole thing with her I remember Naughty
by Nature OPP was on a late night TV
show and I asked to stay up to watch it
and she had to stay up and watch it with
me and she's like what does OPP stand
for
property I said problems and then
whoever the uh well it does though other
people's problems property isn't it
sometimes it's both sometimes it's
doesn't he say it's all three yeah
so luckily he said it because I didn't
want to you know obviously I was nervous
but this is one of my favorite I know
it's all about favorite foods I brought
you guys one of my favorite snacks
they're preschool and Provolone stuffed
hot cherry peppers absolutely love have
you ever had these yeah they're one of
my I had one this week
it's so good and you know what there was
a smaller jar but I was afraid there
wouldn't be enough in case you guys
liked them and you wanted more than one
so I got the biggest one they had I
don't think anyone's ever come with a
gift well thanks by the way Mike fenoia
a hysterical comedian uh dear friend and
also longtime staff member on
Impractical Jokers that's right yeah
yeah uh see half a season five and six
in with the producers and then uh
inside jokes since then still doing it
an after party yeah if you guys watch
yeah you have to party uh Mike's on and
if you watch inside jokes he's the one
that writes all the inside jokes I'm the
one that writes the bubbles I text you
every now and then very weird I think
about sometimes I feel like I let you
down sometimes I'm sorry but no you know
you know who's quick to reply I'll text
mer and he'll call me back
that's like that he's the quickest to
reply but uh yeah please try one of
those I think you'll love them um but
yeah no sometimes I just think about how
weird those texts must be when you get
them yeah you're just out of nowhere
it's like did you ever ride a pony
and I'm like yeah one time yeah it's a
lot of fun and we've done the road
together for years yeah yeah Mike comes
on tour with us uh me and the Jokers
actually all the time yeah yeah it's
been so much fun right now and you've
never been on taste buds yet right no
it's my first time first time I came in
a gift so maybe there will be a second
that's really nice no one's ever brought
a gift to you really I don't think so
that's strange I mean I mean Magnolia
gave us cupcakes once yeah but they
weren't on the show they just like I
just thought about this because I was
like do I bring because there's great
pastries in Italian whatever but I
thought this is something you could keep
in the fridge are you garbage brought
pastries remember that yes okay those
are good too very good dudes yes
I've made my own Shooters at home you
have I've made them yeah you know what I
was worried they're not easy to make
actually it's hard to kind of get it
stuffed right without cracking the sides
yeah yeah and then it's also the key to
a good shooter is you gotta have a firm
pepper
so they're clearly stuffing those things
before they're pickling yes and you
can't it's hard to find I've never found
cherry peppers raw anywhere I've only
ever found them Jarred uh and even then
they're tough to come by and usually
when you find them Jarred they're only
in rings yeah yeah but to find I don't
know where the [__] you get whole cherry
peppers
raw I've never I've literally never seen
it the best thing right think about that
yeah pimp one of the best things right
there that jar maybe only wholesale I I
try to pull those out with a fork to
keep the juice consistent because it's a
nice sandwich juice afterwards that's a
great like that's almost like a
muffaletta type like glazy marinade I
spread it right on some nice focaccios
yeah guys eat one
okay please help yourself he's nervous
it's uh it's a it's a cherry pepper
stuffed with prosciut and provolone it's
not kick it's got a kick there's uh
there weren't Forks but I grabbed like
uh whatever coffee stirrers in there if
you wanna so you can almost skew it okay
that's so nice and we're not even doing
that today because of you we realize we
have never done
you love breakfast all day you're a big
fan of breakfast all day as yes and then
big breakfast are you lunch again lunch
I thought so yeah lunch but honestly
lunch is truly my favorite meal a
favorite meal which I'll get into and
then your dinner now you thought we had
done breakfast and dinner before which
I'm giving him props for we've never
done any of these right and today we're
doing a three-way battle breakfast
versus lunch yeah which I really like
yeah but I realized why you thought we
did that because we did brunch
and we have done we did
I think we did morning versus evening
um and we've done foods that fall into
both categories so we've got to see that
we've never done it yeah but we've never
done the concept and you were like let's
do breakfast first dinner I'm like no
man there's three of us let's do
breakfast lunch and dinner yeah I love
it uh all right are we ready to sure
right
not too impressed
I like it just kind of like oatmeal
consistency and like slimy what oatmeal
to ruin it's so good I mean if you
didn't like it that's cool but I don't
get oatmeal how do you like oatmeal like
granular I don't know I just really
granular it's I like it's fine but I
would never go and seek this out you
wouldn't buy a bucket of them oh dude
when you get a nice deli sandwich have
that as a side or whatever yeah maybe
maybe refrigerant I mean if you get it
again I've done that if you eat that on
the side of a deli like one or two no no
no I'm not knocking I'm saying
that's just that's you have to do a
careful pairing because if you're not
careful you you're eating the same stuff
in the sandwich as you are the wrapper
and it becomes insane you need to have
that on the side of like a turkey and
something so it's not you know what I
mean like you write the book on this
stuff like the salami and provolone the
guy I'm a guy I try to be you're the guy
I mean but you all the guy would
experience sandwiches sure but I mean I
think you know your sandwiches too yeah
I feel like you could own a sandwich
shop if you wanted to yeah yeah don't
you agree yeah yeah I feel like you
could too oh I definitely I'll be honest
with you during the pandemic I thought
about it quite a bit oh well I was gonna
yeah I got a place you might be
interested in remember the idea I had
for a truck yeah yeah what was it
s'mores truck 100 yes you said no one's
doing it but then we found out people
were doing it didn't they Google it yeah
you did
you filled in trucking
they're brought up like 60 Sports trucks
we're thinking about cool names for it I
thought give me some Mo was one oh right
right that's a great name right would
you if you were on the beach and it was
fireworks absolutely love s'mores hate
s'mores yeah you believe that [__] wow
by the way I can't believe we have never
mentioned it I've never been more
justified in my life I've screamed at
South about s'mores or how I hate them
but without the movie The Menu Ray fines
plays a a top-tier chef and his what he
thinks is a a blight on humanity is the
and I was cheering watching this thing
with r shaffir and Ari's like what are
you so and I was like cause [__]
South I was wrong
well you are wrong what is it I mean I
have to go back and watch have you
talked s'mores oh yeah dude we battled
s'mores I forget we battle him against
though
we talked about it on um
when you guys talked about the uh
cookies remember when you had that big
blowout with the
what's what was your famous line that
you said on this podcast goddamn Girl
Scouts yeah you guys were fighting back
and forth about the s'mores trucks
during that battle oh they're worse no
no no no no no no that's not true The
Ether that's not true we were fighting I
said there was no such thing as a cookie
truck oh that's true my apologies yeah
yeah yeah and I said there's ice cream
trucks all over the place
oh I don't think we've done how's that
possible we've definitely done s'mores
we a thousand percent did s'mores
because I went on and on about how like
they don't come together right and doing
it I'm doing a search it's not coming up
I think the only hard thing about a
s'mores truck would be like Rice
Krispies Treats versus s'mores yeah you
got to move them quick because they can
Jill and get weird and crack it's just
[__] food I kind of love them it's just
[__] food it's got the shelf life of of
an avocado a [__] T-cell
it's just forget it yeah I I hate I hate
them I I hate it and I know cookie
trucks there's got to be some Portland
Oregon cookie station we found we found
some but that was it's not in the it's
not that was one of the reasons we were
screaming is because Sarah was going see
there's cookie trucks but I was like but
there's not cookie trucks let me let me
just put this in
it's time to
b-a-t-t-o
breakfast breakfast don't get me wrong I
like every meal right we're just I'm I'm
saying why is one meal better than the
other meal breakfast love it it starts
today a lot of people say it's the most
important when I'm in the mood for
breakfast nothing else can quench that
except breakfast I'm a big fan of
breakfast all day breakfast is great
toast is one of my favorite things
breakfast is terribly limiting I think
oh I think that you know you'd be
hard-pressed to really get outside the
box on breakfast it has its Staples and
that's cool when I don't feel like
having breakfast you know what I mean
like it's just like breakfast is like
like when I don't want eggs I'm like oh
I get that away from me you know what I
mean so breakfast is great but it is
limiting okay now lunch
is fun I want to can I buy one on
breakfast first yeah please
it's the first meal to go
it's the first meal to go it's the first
one you cut out of your schedules you
don't think you laugh out lunch
heavy breakfast get you to dinner yeah
no totally you skip breakfast you start
with lunch yeah but lunch yeah but then
you're gonna be starving by lunch and
you can be full for dinner late lunch
light lunch late lunch like I did today
not late early light lunch if you're
eliminating breakfast I did a turkey
sandwich with tomato lettuce no dresses
that wasn't like on rye it was that much
turkey nothing
I didn't feel sick after okay uh why
would you feel sick after breakfast
almost exclusively do I feel sick after
what do you eating what are you eating
for breakfast I had to I had to stop I
had to cut out almost all breakfast
foods here's why when I only ate
when I ate like on this no you shocked
me every day when I
the sugary stuff at breakfast like
pancakes or or french toast or whatever
my sugar would spike and drop so hard
that later I would start shaking where I
had to pound like a Coke because it
would just cause such an imbalance of
sugar in my in my day
eggs bacon sausage complete grease gives
me a stomachache makes me feel terrible
buy breakfast food at this point if I do
breakfast which I never do anymore I
never do breakfast anymore that's crazy
uh is is some coffee and maybe some
fruit that's why yeah that's why you
leave your house with a [__] dude
you got to get your nutrients a good
hearty breakfast let me ask you a
question now because you said you like
breakfast all day if you eat breakfast
for dinner aren't you eating dinner
no we're talking about the food I'm
talking about the food traditionally the
cuisine in the morning because I'll tell
you right now you could eat breakfast
for dinner and I could eat anything at
lunch for dinner but you can't eat
dinner at breakfast and you can't eat
dinner really at lunch what am I
wouldn't do it I don't want you would
need
scallops roll all over at seven in the
morning and give my wife a kid let's go
get some meatloaf right now now I don't
want that I'm saying but but versatility
of dinner to be able to have anything
that you have that's the beauty of lunch
pulls from both directions it's like
when you go to a resort right and
there's like three hotels and this
bracelet can only go there this bracelet
could go into that and that and then you
pay all the big bucks and this bracelet
can go in all three of them dinner is
the third bracelet
dinner I can have I could have no
breakfast for dinner I got everything
for lunch for dinner you can anything
you have for dinner you can have for
lunch people do it all the time look at
what businessmen do where they go for
lunch they go to sit down and they sit
down at steakhouses they have a martini
at a steak but you're talking about a
businessman I'm just saying you could do
anything
I've worked in many a facility okay I
worked with senior citizens a lot before
I got into comedy and stuff I worked was
that before the hip-hop career
you know
you know he got rid of that but then he
got a job where he could lead by example
okay all right he he grabbed people
breakfast is the only meal that you
could make into a hip-hop name be fast
that's it anyway listen here
[Music]
you know I have a great uh hip-hop name
I have a great hip-hop name I might have
told you before carte blanche come on no
and then one time I saw it on the
independent hip-hop uh flyer I don't
like it it's a car Blanche Pro cart
Blanche I like it the name is Fun the
whole uh premise around this fun the
theme is fun you know what hip-hop name
and which one to use Victor spoils
all right listen I'm gonna go with you
on carte blanche all right but I would
say carb launch
but why can't launch
why Vic spoils it just sounds cooler
yeah but carb launch isn't anything
carte blanche Vic spoils isn't anything
yeah but it's Victor spoils Carr
is Cart Car Blanche is confusing
I'm trying to build something with you
here you know what I mean you know
South South Bronx
all right I think carb lunch is kind of
cool you know the good thing about
omelettes is that wait
[Laughter]
do whatever you yeah no I just this is
it you don't need to be happy I didn't I
didn't finish my point remember what my
Goddamn point was oh lunch is any meal
lunch is any meal you can do any meal at
lunch listen this whole lunch but
breakfast could be any meal if you land
late and you're D whatever breakfast
lunch dinner could be at any time of the
day oh I worked in a lot of Institutions
and they would eat like meatloaf and
potatoes and green beans at lunch time
okay all right
like institutional food yeah that's what
it's called sure but that's a very Niche
specific thing I'm just saying this dude
you're crazy if you think you gotta
eliminate one you're not eliminating
lunch yeah you wake up you start your
day you get the energy for the day and
then you finish your day over here by
the way if dinner has the most options
let's be honest breakfast is the one
they tell you to get rid of
I heard breakfast isn't
this is the most options
Factor influencing weight outcomes and
dietary quality based on evidence
of e intermediate fasting as one
strategy to use working together once
again thank you car Blanche
here's the thing that's the meal they
tell you to cut breakfast no it does not
no it doesn't happen about time zone no
for foreign like for your beloved
McDonald's after decades and decades and
decades and decades to to make the turn
and say we're now going to do breakfast
all day what does that tell you about
breakfast breakfast Man People Want it
no I think there are so many apps
there's definitely not less options for
breakfast all the different ways you can
do eggs all the different pizzas for
breakfast omelettes are a vehicle for I
mean [__] it's a pallet you put anything
you want in there omelets suck no they
don't omelettes suck you suck um
dry it's too much eggs it never tastes
right you gotta dress it up with some
ketchup it's never really sucked but
honestly though a nice scrambled egg
omelette I could name the breakfast
foods right now and I can do it I can't
name the dinner foods dinner foods it's
infinite come on I know you got your
eggs have you ever got your toast you
got your sausage you got your bacon you
got your pastries you got your waffles
you got your your Flapjacks you got your
French toast you got your uh granola
maybe you got some oatmeal uh I'm
running out have you ever killed have
you ever gone let me and I mean but then
because if you were going if you were
gone have you ever gone have I ever gone
to a we've all been to buffets there's
lunch style buffets which by the way the
lunch buffet is usually lunch slash
dinner foods okay breakfast buffet
that's absolutely true and you know it's
true now they draw a hard line they take
the lunch foods out no no they do not
sell maybe maybe
shout I go to buffets every time I'm in
a casino town I go to a buffet for lunch
it's the first thing I do you can get
prime rib slice still at lunch it's it's
dinner foods what's not there's the
breakfast foods breakfast buffet is its
own thing okay but I will tell you this
have you ever gone
to a breakfast buffet it looks like if
Willy Wonka was sentencing you to some
sort of nightmare punishment where he's
like oh you like to eat do you here's
cakes and cookies and hams
[Laughter]
eggs all these potatoes breakfast
like you mix those things
the only meal where they slide desserts
onto the entree what's wrong with the
entree list it's batshit yeah
see the hardest day you're having a
rough day you call home you go let's
babe breakfast for dinner tonight it's
just such a nice feeling you're saying
okay so you're saying it's like a
comfort food yes it's amazing at any
time of the day when I fly across the
country and I didn't get to eat
breakfast when I get to the hotel I want
breakfast I don't care what time
when I was a kid my mom once in a while
would go how about we do breakfast for
dinner tonight and and I had to say out
loud yes
in my head I was saying you lazy son of
a [__] you're gonna put [__] eggs
into it
Foreigner would be my mom would make
fried chicken meatballs from all of it
from scratch steak meatloaf from scratch
breakfast for dinner Sit Down You're
Gonna crack a few eggs into a pan with
some bacon it takes five minutes to put
together and by the way you're not full
after either yeah
it's fun I will say this so I don't want
anything but breakfast during breakfast
time I will say that that's for you I
will say that but at dinner whatever I
feel goes it's very freeing that's right
okay and you don't go to like an
important event like a wedding people
don't have a wedding and give out
breakfast food people don't have a
wedding and give out eggs the weddings
are at night there's dinner right away
actually it's mostly I need to disagree
with you on this on on behalf of all
three meals
I have to disagree with you a wedding
when they pull out the stops we'll
feature all three meals you've got a
cocktail hour featuring lunch style
Foods
cocktail hours appetizers
so it's it's it's it's a lot it's cured
meats it's cheeses it's fingers that's
called an antipast
which is a lunch yeah you have to be a
dinner it's salads it's things like that
then yourself for dinner and then you go
no I mean of course of course like you
know but but
I'm not sure you're stretching by people
right now no because then you go to
dinner I wouldn't I wouldn't eat a
charcuterie for dinner I eat it for
lunch
I eating any pasta for lunch charcuterie
has a palette as a moose booze here's my
point my point is is you got lunch and
meats and stuff being served at the
cocktail hour you got mini burgers you
got pigs in a blanket those are lunchy
kinds of foods okay I go more dinner
I'm about to defend all three of these
okay okay can I get a credit out I just
think that you're
saying that appetizers at a wedding or
lunch food I don't think they're
appetizers I think they're finger foods
and I think a lot of the times it's a
cocktail hour
I think a quesadilla to me at a mini
quesadilla to me feels way more like a
lunch style food than than just
crossover
right yeah as a dinner then you go and
you can add and then you have
traditional dinner and it's like it's
steak it's it's a half a chicken it's a
salmon whatever the hell you get then
next day
hey everybody we got breakfast they do
all three usually at the event Joe not
everybody's doing next day stay over
have breakfast the next day I'll tell
you what you work a long hard day what
are you looking forward to all day a
french toast getting out of that office
you're going to dinner you all day what
are we doing for dinner tonight what are
we doing oh what do you want to do you
want to cook you want to go out for
dinner you want to order for dinner okay
at the end at the end of the day it's
like I can't wait to go home and die
I'll give you the food don't get excited
when you hear think breakfast for dinner
they don't get excited about that no
breakfast or dinner is dinner but no if
this is your only argument no it's not
you better step it up because you're
this is going nowhere breakfast is one
of the only meals that I will wait in
line for like I'll go to like a nice
like already breakfast place and wait in
line
who's waiting in line for dinner nobody
I'm not because you don't wait in line
for dinner what are you going to a
freaking what are you nuts you wait in
line for dinner not fast food
what are you crazy how many restaurants
you go to they go it's a 45 minute wait
for dinner what are you talking about
none yeah well sure I want him in iced
tea when they're done playing Mortal
Kombat I'm sorry but he gets his own
table because he videotaped himself
peeing into the soup in the back for
[__] true TV
anyway yeah
um no but I God damn it you just said
something that that
no no no no what did you say right
before that
um I said that I consider breakfast at
dinner dinner
oh let me go to the flip side of what
you just said about what do you wait for
all day at work
dinner so two parts of this lunch
that is the that's your break at work
you can't wait to get to lunch because
you know you finally get out of the
office you get to go get away from it
all you get to eat lunch and then you go
when I get back I only have this many
hours left and I get to so that's
something
that's a function of downtime not
necessarily with a meal
there's much it's more than it is to me
I I I when I had a regular nine to five
job I would be lunch at your desk are
you like I can't wait till lunch I was
excited but it's less I was excited well
of course because you're taking a break
from work but I was just a breakfast
break but I will tell you on jobs where
there's a breakfast truck that rolls up
and you go out okay a bacon egg and
cheese and a coffee and it's the best
thing ever but also I'll tell you this
I'll tell you this and this is a strike
against dinner dinner is the only pain
in the ass meal dinner is the only meal
where you're like I'm too [__] tired
I can't even think about it oh my God we
have nothing in the house at a lunch no
matter where you are when you are if you
don't have anything in the house you go
ah whatever it's running the deli you
get a sandwich whatever breakfast uh if
we got stuff we'll eat it if we don't
we'll skip it maybe we get a yogurt
whatever dinner is the only one where
you're like [__] delivery is 75
minutes right now
exclusively for someone who is going to
cook dinner and realize that they're out
of stuff in their fridge dinner is kind
of realistic dinner you know what I say
oh there's nothing in the fridge oh I
pull up my doordash
yeah and it's the longest wait times no
I just order whatever I want it's dinner
but it's the longest way there's no not
like God damn it there's nothing in the
house there's a bottleneck that happens
with dinner who's the guy that wrote
Infinite Jest what's that guy's name the
author's name
the guy that killed himself
David Foster Wallace that picture is
from the speech he gave there's a this
is majorly viral he gave a very very
famous commencement speech called
I think it's called it's just water or
something like that but anyway the
example he uses in that speech about how
self-centered we can all act is when you
get out of work and have to go to the
supermarket after work to figure out
dinner and the entire self-centeredness
of Life of this is because the the
supermarkets mob there's traffic you're
hungry it's going to take too long
that's not it it all revolves around
dinner and it's brilliant and it's an
amazing whatever blah blah blah listen
to it but my point is is dinner there is
a bottlenecking that happens at dinner
time that does not happen at any other
meal except for breakfast on Saturday
and Sunday it'll happen Church hours but
you do not have that kind of
bottlenecking [__] because I used to
work in an office well in any popular
place in the neighborhood we got our
lunch break we were like I don't know I
gotta hurry up and get down there
because I'm gonna wait on the [__]
line
as well as a matter of fact dinner can
happen at five six seven eight or nine
lunch is usually happening between 12
and 1 11 30 like that so there's no
greater pointed bottom one two three
people wrapped around the corner to get
a sandwich for lunch because that's the
time everyone has lunch so take your
bottleneck and put it somewhere else in
you
also I don't like that lunch can
overextend itself you ever uh go into a
restaurant and it's 4 30 and they're
like I just want to get some lunch
you're like no no we dinner starts at
five we stopped lunch
what's your arrogant ass dinner butting
its noses no it's not dinner's got to be
the star of the show for dinner no we
got to be the only I don't know is there
a break between breakfast and lunch
and they go no lunch starts in two hours
because we're in the in between
breakfast and lunch it only happens
between lunch and dinner they start
breakfast service for lunch though for
sure but then lunch comes out with lunch
hours and they stop lunch there's no
food like breakfast starts I mean dinner
starts at five and they they just stop
the lunch lunch can't see through to
dinner I've I've I have not seen in a
long time last week that that goes dark
in between lunch oh dude it happened
overextended stuff what that is is a
different menu coming in at dinner that
needs to be prepped for and they can't
keep they can't do both so they need
downtime but you just told me that you
really even see that I'm saying when
that happens that's what that is but why
isn't that between breakfast and lunch
because it speaks to my point about
breakfast for dinner because breakfast
is a bullshit-ass meal no that anybody
can throw together at any time of day
and it doesn't take any thought or
effort let's let's be honest even though
I like them let's be honest when you
think of lunch you think of one thing I
think over everything else sandwiches
yeah so I mean you know um I mean you
know I love a sandwich a sandwich is one
of my favorite food foods like Joey
Tribbiani you watching friends uh but
but uh but but but but for you I mean
you got you're nothing without a
sandwich you're nothing yeah what are
you so versatile
Sushi those are all dinner ideas
soup sandwiches are dinner items right
sandwiches and dinner breakfast is
extremely versatile dinner all the time
what are you talking about breakfast is
extremely versatile and it's also a
vehicle for so many great syrups and
sauces and all different types
what comes to mind first eggs when I say
lunch what comes to mine first sandwich
when I say dinner what comes to mind
first steak you can't even name
you both agreed on eggs you both agreed
on sandwiches no denying it you could
deny steak means dinner if I say the V
what do you think of when you think of
dinner you know steak I would say Pasta
Pasta pimp what would you say dinner
what comes to your mind okay you know
what I'm saying I'm making a good point
here yeah but you could put steak get an
omelette you could put steak and and I
know what I'm saying yes I do because
that dinner are such that you can't
pinpoint down what is the the the there
are breakfast menus there are breakfast
restaurants that specialize just in
breakfast and they have just as big a
menu as any like my point was if you
think of breakfast you think of eggs if
you think of lunch you take a sandwich
if you think of dinner it's anybody's
ball game babe but that's like saying if
you think of meat what do you think a
cow like there's so many things
no eggs is to breakfast what cow would
be to me like I would say like there's
so many things you could do with that
you can make a burger you can make
sausage you can make a million different
things just like with eggs it's the
batter on French toast it's there's so
many different things that you could do
with it
you got sandwiches so like you got fish
you got chicken you got it's all
breakfast pasta you have I mean you have
you have first of all when I think of a
meal I see an immediate food spread in
my head that's what I see when you say
dinner I see all these things together
on a thing right but I do that but I do
that with lunch and I did it but but my
point is is I do that with breakfast too
my point is is with lunch the the you're
condemning it because it managed to
bring a Titan staple pill or food into
the mix you can eat whatever you want
for lunch nobody cares just because they
have something that is so a
representative of the meal doesn't
lessen the meal that is an asset to the
meal I would say dinner to me is a
gluttonous experience where there's too
many choices and by the way dinner's the
only choices of the negative well but
dinner because dinner's a meal where if
you don't do it right
you're [__] pissed off the rest of
the night yeah and you're making
everything you're making eggs you're
unique
people are pissed off because they
[__] up dinner for the rest tell me
something tell me something can you mess
up anything tell me something how many
lunches
I'm talking you go out and you buy it
how many lunches or breakfasts have you
gone to breakfast
how many of those have you gone to in a
restaurant
or shop or whatever
and when it was bad been Furious for me
not many I'm disappointed but not
Furious when I get a bad dinner at a
sit-down restaurant I am furious
by the way you want to talk another
thing the up charge at dinner is absurd
yeah what they're charging at dinner for
these Foods I'm with you in our
restaurants and you're talking about the
ones that are doing up charges this is
again very Niche let's talk about the
biological standpoint okay okay if you
only have to eat one meal a day it's
either breakfast or lunch yeah your meal
one meal a day is not lunch I don't
think you need something you can't wait
till lunch to eat and you know if you're
really trying to be healthy you get all
that stuff in you get your nutrients you
get your energy and fuel for the day and
you burn it off or you waiting all day
long you got to eat dinner at the end of
the night to get you through overnight
okay if there's anything that's
Expendable it's lunch look at this
dinner is generally the most expensive
meal of the day dinner tends to be a
larger meal because it includes
appetizers entrees So reading comments
desserts
this is a chat yeah dude yeah so but I'm
saying my point is is that it just said
what I just said it's a gluttonous meal
it's like dinner dinner comes it dinner
is the man spreading of meals it flops
down its legs are wide open it doesn't
listen to anybody are you wild bro
dinner is a family institution it's the
threaded fabric of our society as people
people come to break bread that's dinner
people sit down families at the end of
the day dad comes home kids home from
school they only have an hour together
you sit at the dinner table and you eat
together at the dinner table it
represents more than just an expensive
up charge at a restaurant dinner is is
or like anything else it's a staple in
our lives it's more than that lunch is
not that yeah lunch isn't breakfast is
in second place and that's all you're
talking about I agree Saturday Sunday
you sit down any family breakfast I
agree do you think lunch is made up
comments right now and I'm getting so
angry do you think that lunch is made up
of do you think that lunch is made up of
leftovers more than any other meal like
do you think 100 lunch dinner left over
there's dinner leftovers or lunch yeah
yeah you can take my [__] cold
leftovers that's what you have in
tomorrow buddy for your lunch my
leftovers are good enough for you a meal
that's what it's saying uh I love
leftovers at lunch but I do not think
it's primarily what is eaten if you're
gonna eat leftovers you're gonna
probably eat them for lunch uh I would
say something sometimes sure yeah until
the 19 until the early 19th century
luncheon was generally reserved for the
ladies for the ladies who would often
have lunch with one another when their
husbands were out the meal was often
relatively light and often included
leftovers from the previous night's
dinner which were often plentiful uh as
a as of late as late as 1945 Emily post
wrote in the magazine etiquette that
luncheon is generally given by in four
women but it is not unusual especially
in summer places Sunny to include an
equal number of men I love it so ladies
yeah I didn't know anything that means I
love I love a ladies
lunch and see those ladies with the pink
hats
you've seen them right yeah yeah
the pink Hat Society of some [__] yeah I
didn't know about that the one time and
I was like yo did I drop ass like
there's 15 old ladies of fancy Amish
so you all know about this
I know about that group like it's like
middle-aged women that get together and
wear pink hats why do they do it the
pink hat group but well it's just it's
just it's just like it's like a thing
like that it's like ladies lunch stuff
yeah but why wear the pink hats why
I feel if I go to a place and they have
breakfast all day I'm definitely
considering that as my life no matter
what time of the day it is I agree and
that's why I feel like breakfast is the
most versatile and the most go-to we're
not going somewhere at eight in the
morning and looking for like meatloaf
and mashed potatoes I'm never but I will
go at nine o'clock about versatility you
can have anything from your two from
your two meals you can have any of those
at dinner and it's socially completely
acceptable and done all the time right
that's versatility that's dinner I have
throughout my entire life eaten
primarily lunch foods as the first meal
of the day no matter how early it is I
have I remember being out with who it's
now his wife but I was with my friend
Jim who was engaged at the time and I
remember getting into an argument with
not an argument but it got tense because
we were visiting and I wanted to get he
didn't he his his fiancee was like
didn't want to get pizza for breakfast
and I remember he was like it was that
moment where your boy like you realize
there's somebody else now yeah and he
was like he's like Jess it's perfectly
reasonable that you would not want to
eat pizza for breakfast and I was like
what are you talking about dude like we
she had to pull his mask off that's how
like that's how much we did it right can
I that's how often I do do did that I
don't do it anymore but can I make
another point
you got two experiences in breakfast and
dinner that you don't have at lunch for
the most part okay you wake up in the
morning sometimes you're woken up by the
smell of coffee by the smell of bacon
yeah you sizzling it's like oh my God
it's breakfast smell the breakfast
that's very nice dinner same thing
you're upstairs in the room all of a
sudden you smell the sauce being made or
whatever's being made oh my God the
dinner smells good you don't for the
most part you don't hear oh smell the
lunch yeah you hear the cold country
lunch I'll tell you when you smell the
lunch
somebody fires up that grill outside
yeah but how often is that happening
doesn't matter we're talking about how
often are you waking up to the gentle
sense of bacon it's not showing very
over the weekends pretty often well I
live alone but never die but that's a
literal thing that like that's a thing
that people well that was a thing I also
and I would say that the smell of the
grill on a summer's day that's a
lunchtime thing and that's also pretty
[__] awesome and I think that's
something that I also think and you hit
a good point I love a cup a hot cup of
coffee with my meal and breakfast is
that meal I'm not gonna have a cup of
coffee with chicken cutlets you're right
I'm not gonna have a cup of coffee
with a nice cappuccino
or a coffee I'll finish my bit now you
finished meals with coffee we have
absolutely dinner yes lunch is the only
meal where you don't really get coffee
right I I will say by the way lunch is
gonna lose
clearly dinner is going to win no I'm
telling you let's go to the pharmacy
believe that all three of these anyone
could have any opinion on these and I
thought it was going to be a Thruway
very close that's what and I'll tell you
what too it also kind of depends on the
life you're living because if you're
waking if you're working nights you may
eat meatloaf at nine in the morning when
you get home take a dump smoke a
cigarette go to sleep but that's that
nine in the morning is your dinner time
that's the thing well that see that's
where I'm thinking dinner for breakfast
oh that's the one and only way I also
think you're sleeping on brunch it might
have impacted lunch and breakfast in
general yeah
but brunch lost to I don't know it
didn't brunch beat happy hour I believe
okay I'll tell you what I tried to love
an egg on a burger I can't do it I tried
to not permit it I have grown to almost
almost entirely hate the egg almost in
time you like a quail egg over some nice
asparagus
once in a while I get a craving for like
like a like like a nice dippy egg on a
toasted bagel and you bite it and like
the juice shoots out
I'm not saying I I don't want you to
want to get a craving but I'm telling
you eggs have really left my eggs trying
to make it extra to make their way into
some dishes that maybe they shouldn't be
around I can't tell that makes me more
Angry than egg and fried rice I hate
when there's egg and fried rice
you like a nice hard-boiled egg in a
Cobb salad I don't like that at all
really I love the one big fan of the
hard boiled I hate the yolk of a
hard-boiled egg soft boiled egg love it
uh all right we got to go to the phones
uh okay what's better than breakfast at
dinner
lunch the most versatile meal thank you
everything is lunch thank you all three
at once lunch food is just Superior okay
wow 24-hour breakfast is stupid
breakfast for dinner wow when you're
when you're Diner you're not getting
like a couple eggs and hold on here
I gotta be honest you two are doing
really good food type of food breakfast
food is the best
um based on type of food breakfast IHOP
Denny's McDonald's 24-hour breakfast
menu you need I say more oh my god I've
never been the first vote before okay
nothing comes close to McDonald's
breakfast I agree McDonald's breakfast
is is throws the gauntlet down it's the
one breakfast food where I'm like okay I
get it you can eat everything for dinner
but it's not the same eating dinner
lunch items for breakfast correct that's
it yeah dinner is the meal in most
dinner meal I'm most awake for and
generally enjoy the most lunches lunch
is just used to
used to get from point A to point B of a
shitty work day love it breakfast Blows
By the way by the way can I say this
no family's ever had an awkward lunch
come on oh well no family's ever dinner
dinner is the meal dinner is the meal
that all pain happens around breakups
family fights all tension you got to get
together
not true that happens 100 breakfast is
breakfast is fake lunches Energizer
dinner is required for survival
biologically I said that no way listen
when you're a kid and you wake up
cereal you want Lucky Charms you want
Cinnamon Toast Crunch what I mean you're
having a rough oh man dinner's the king
there's so many great no matter what's
the best you all agree lunch is the
worst dinner is the King breakfast is
Queen lunch is a jester
you don't start the day with a steak and
mashed potatoes for a reason babe
breakfast yep
uh
uh nice cup of coffee mix biscuits and
gravy crunch country fried country fried
steak and home fries is the greatest
meal of all time right there my wife's
boyfriend likes breakfast so I'll go
with dinner
that's funny
that guy's great my wife's boyfriend
okay follow at locked in letter N loaded
OD all right Mike give your plugs we got
to do the Humble Pie segment at Mike
fenoia
m-i-k-e-f-i-n-o-i-a bunch of dates on
mikevanoia.com comes the time podcast I
co-host with otil Burbridge from dead
company uh check it out very cool all
right we got six only six thousand votes
almost seven thousand uh light voting
load today here we go drum roll pimpy
him choosing dinner
you know
I I could I could see that I could see
that no
dinner coming in uh with nearly half of
49.49.3 you got breakfast right there at
31.8 and lunch in last place at 18. I'm
not surprised this makes me so mad right
that's how I would rank them he somehow
weasels into a win every episode I said
on the texture you saw it let's do
breakfast versus dinner and I wish would
have been on team dinner and I would
have won he goes no babe breakfast lunch
dinner
okay then I'll do lunch I guess and he
goes he goes ooh I guess I could do
dinner let's let's
Sal breakfast first dinner will be
killer we've never done either I just
checked I said wow we've never done
either did we do lunch versus anything
if not a triple battle breakfast lunch
dinner may be cool Joe answers with a
snippy [__] no hence my exact words in
quotes we've never done either of these
[Music]
yeah that's why I said so this is
Ron Burgundy blown into a conch shell to
start the fight
yeah I wrote back to him I wrote back to
him take it easy Slappy and then Joe
writes quote unquote I love a triple
battle Mike breakfast me lunch salad
dinner that's out that's what he typed
okay also give me credit that I said
haha the Slappy thing showing that a
sense of humor
I'm gonna give you credit for saying
haha to slap it in because I pointed out
the fact that you were getting snippy
for no reason I I was being funny snippy
all right and you were being funny back
I'm dropping funny now Happy's not I
knew that I was coming into a loving
situation yeah yeah but you know I just
want to say you heard the text message I
love it let's do triple and then he
assigned us and that's before anything
was assigned all right that's fine
it's just weird how you always kind of
end up on the winning it's just a little
weird well I guess you shouldn't give me
dinner and say you love the triple
battle all right fine fair enough anyway
folks uh let's be honest you pick you
pick who you representing let's just
give this this is why I like breakfast
because conversations like this don't
happen at breakfast this is a dinner
this is dinner [__] you are a man
you are a man of your own free will
right you pick who you're gonna argue
with for
so maybe you gotta just reflect
okay make the change Shimon all right
what are we doing say the line the close
the shop
I still love you babe I love you too de
la forever taste buds they come into the
mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
Fool's gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste buds